Charlie you're a good dancer
a writer's inspired by a novel or an
article or season old film they take the
germ of the idea or the skeleton of the
story put it into the hopper and it
comes out reimagined
sometimes they start completely from
scratch facing the terror of the blank
page relying only on pure imagination
the origins of many great screenplays
are often a mess they come from some
inner light or inner darkness or a
writer that just needs a job
but a good writer the right writer can
hear and feel how to make a story come
to life
here are the nominees for adapted
screenplay Chris Terrio for our NGO
based on a selection from the master of
disguise by Antonio J Mendez and a Wired
magazine article The Great Escape by
Joshua Pearman you see Al Abbar and Ben
Zeitlin for beasts of the southern wild
based on the play juicy and delicious by
lucy olive our David Magee for Life of
Pi based on the novel by Yann Martel
Tony Kushner for Lincoln based in part
on the book team of rivals political
genius at Abraham Lincoln by Doris
Kearns Goodwin
David O'Russell for silver linings
playbook based on the novel by Matthew
quake and the Oscar goes to Chris Terrio
Argo
this is the first Academy Award and
nominated
and for Chris Terrio
[Applause]
[Music]
well I want to say I share this with the
other people in my category Lucy and Ben
and David and David and Tony brilliant
Tony thank you for inspiring me thank
you
Ben Affleck been 15 years ago you were
up here with the first screenplay you
got made and now you made this film us
brought me up here and it's a gift and I
can never repay it and thank you I love
you um I want to thank Warner Brothers
everybody at smokehouse George Grant and
you know I want to thank my mom and dad
my friends who propped me up every day
in all this
Josh Berman and I want to dedicate this
to a man named Tony Mendez 33 years ago
Tony using nothing but his creativity
and his intelligence got six people out
of a very bad situation and so I want to
dedicate this to him and the Taylor's
and the shear downs and people all over
the world in the US and Canada in Iran
they use creativity and intelligence to
solve problems non-violently thank you
[Applause]